ya q pérez no detiene su lucha el
candidato por el movimiento pachakutik y
que ha denunciado un presunto fraude
electoral tras los resultados del
proceso llevado a cabo el 7 de febrero
espera alzar su voz en quito y poco
parece importar el anuncio del consejo
nacional electoral que te claro a
guillermo lasso como contendor de andré
zarautz en el balotaje del próximo 11 de
abril pero lo lindo de la verdadera
elección los verdaderos resultados desde
el corazón de los ecuatorianos
organizada por las principales
confederaciones de pueblos indígenas la
caminata comenzó en loja al sur del país
el 17 de febrero adicionalmente recorrió
las localidades de cuenca chimborazo
salcedo y cotopaxi esta última a pocos
kilómetros de la ciudad de quito en la
capital ecuatoriana aspiran llevar a
cabo una serie de acciones entre ellas
una manifestación ante el cn pero las
autoridades han desplegado un amplio
operativo de seguridad y piden a los
manifestantes mantener la cordura en la
nación todavía está fresco el recuerdo
de las protestas llevadas a cabo en
octubre de 2019 lideradas por el
movimiento indígena
como hemos tomado todas las previsiones
para poder controlar una situación
adversa que podría presentarse en la
ciudad capital para esto se ha
coordinado con las diferentes
instituciones partiendo desde los
controles del ingreso a la ciudad
capital a fin de que cada institución
cumpla con su rol de distintas visiones
y guillermo lasso asegura mantener su
brazo extendido para dialogar con las
diferentes fuerzas políticas de cara a
la segunda vuelta no descarta un posible
acercamiento con pérez pero sólo si éste
lo invita